why
so if Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe
part four we of course get the
conclusion of this story then what we're
going to see is that all the pieces are
going to fall into place that we're
going to fully understand what it is a
Deadpool is doing but more specifically
the story's going to end in a really
interesting way it's going to into the
way that I think is really unique and
something that really could have only
been done with a Deadpool story now as
we start this this comic we pick up with
the press with the media as they're
covering some kind of massive I guess
onslaught or event and what we're
learning is that various superheroes and
supervillains are all fighting one
another they're all killing one another
and what the press is telling us here is
that this appears to be perhaps some
kind of a brutal war that's going on no
one really understands what's taking
place but they know that it's most
likely due to the fallout of the actions
of Deadpool who's been going about and
killing various superheroes and
supervillains in addition the press
points our direction to the top of one
of the buildings and what we see are
superheroes and supervillains who are
standing on top of this building and
throwing themselves off and this is
really interesting to us because what
this does is it more or less just gives
us his explanation that Deadpool himself
didn't actually kill every single
superhero directly that these other
superheroes and supervillains were
killed by various means and as the press
is giving us this explanation in terms
of how society is viewing these actions
that while some of them claim is the end
end of days and some of them claim that
is the hubris of superheroes and
supervillains finally catching up to
them we see that somebody is presumably
using a sniper rifle and is looking at
these various individuals ultimately the
view of this person switches to a window
and it appears as though he's currently
aiming at Deadpool and what we learn is
that this person is Frank castle and
Frank Castle takes this time to shoot
Deadpool through the window that he was
aiming at and so from here Frank Castle
immediately takes off telling us that
he's going to try to get back to
Deadpool to kill him before his healing
factor comes into play but once Frank
Castle gets into the apartment he had
shot into and he takes off the mask of
Deadpool he realizes this is not
Deadpool
that this is in fact puppet master and
the puppet master had been using puppets
that he had created of various
superheroes and supervillains to force
these people against their will to jump
off the building or else engage in
conflict with one another and what we
learn is that Deadpool is in fact in
this room and Deadpool sneaks up behind
Frank castle and of course Deadpool has
one of the puppets that have been made
by puppet master in the form of Frank
Castle and he begins to mock Frank
Ashley begins to poke fun at him with
regards to Frank castles war Journal and
so on but what Deadpool does is he uses
the doll to point a gun that it's
holding at its own head there by forcing
dead or forcing a Frank Castle to point
a gun at his head and of course Deadpool
simulates the doll pulling the trigger
and Frank Castle shoots himself in the
head and so from here we hear that a
Deadpool is talking about how he has a
much bigger scheme going on that Frank
Castle whenever he was involved in his
escapades had always been on the small
level he'd always done small things but
Deadpool has much bigger plans in terms
of what he wants to achieve and so from
here we transition to the lair of the
man thing and what we have is we have a
circumstance whereby taskmaster that the
his search for Deadpool has led him to
the Florida Everglades and so as he's
transitioning through this place as he's
moving around he finally comes across
Deadpool and what he tells Deadpool is
that he's been chasing him for quite
some time and that everything that's
taken place will come to an end at this
this location within the Everglades that
perhaps a time will come when maybe the
actions of Deadpool will be forgotten
but the third voice in Deadpool's head
says they don't want to be forgotten but
they don't want to have ever existed in
the first place and so what we notice
here and this is something very
important as we continue with this story
is the taskmaster over here is the third
voice and Deadpool's head he here's what
it is a third voice is saying now again
this will become important in the next
few pages but what we have is where
Deadpool simply replies to I guess
replied a taskmaster saying that he
didn't say anything that he didn't
actually say anything out loud
and so taskmaster doesn't seem to
initially catch on to this but what
Deadpool says is that he's glad
taskmaster showed up that all these
other individuals all these other aliens
and all these other people who had the
capability of reading minds
had done what they could to stop
Deadpool but in the end they would most
likely be taskmaster and the reason why
as is explained to us as far as a
Deadpool in his discussion is the
taskmaster has the ability to begin
mimicking people that he's able to
predict what what it is they're going to
do because he can mimic them and as he
mimics Deadpool he begins to think like
Deadpool he begins to function like
Deadpool and when he does he begins to
realize what it is a Deadpool is getting
into what it is a Deadpool is trying to
achieve and Deadpool tells taskmaster
this he of course with his third voice
points out that a taskmaster is
beginning to mimic his reflexes
beginning to mimic what it is a Deadpool
is doing and so the third voice tells
Deadpool to have taskmaster open his
eyes to have taskmaster understand was
taking place and so Deadpool speaks
directly to taskmaster in saying that
every time he imitates somebody he in
effect eventually becomes that person so
long as he is fighting them and so
taskmaster realizes what it is a
Deadpool's doing here but before he's
actually able to do anything else
Deadpool tells taskmaster that it could
be frightening that he knows it can be
scary but that individuals who show fear
within the Florida Everglades will burn
at the touch of the man thing and so we
see that the Man Thing arrives and a
destroys taskmaster and so from here
Deadpool begins talking with the man
thing begins conversing with the man
thing and sort of relating to the man
thing here saying that the man thing
doesn't really have much of a valuable
existence that he simply just shows up
he protects the nexus of realities and
that's it there's really no other
purpose in his life and so it appears as
though the man thing is beginning to
understand what it is a Deadpool wants
to do the man thing is beginning to
maybe empathize with Deadpool we don't
exactly know what his mindset is here
but ultimately it's revealed to us that
the man-things sacrifices itself an
order for Deadpool to achieve its goal
and so the the Amanda thing explodes and
when he explodes he more or less reveals
the portal to the Nexus of all realities
and so what we see is Deadpool entering
this nexus of all realities and what
happens here is a third voice comes into
play the third voice says that this is
only the beginning
to that Deadpool basically has his work
cut out for him but what Deadpool is
hunting for is the I guess the center of
all realities the point at which all of
the other realities stem from
effectively the location or I guess the
real world where the writers are or
they're making all these different
realities and so what we see is a
Deadpool eventually rise within the real
world and when he does he begins looking
around he begins hunting around and he
comes across a room and when he does all
the writers that are currently writing
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe are
talking about what it is a Deadpool is
going to be doing and so as they're
writing this story Deadpool is currently
trying to track them down and so what
happens as the story begins to come to a
close is that Deadpool begins to enter
the room but before he does he looks
back he breaks the fourth wall and he
tells us as the reader that he's going
to be coming for us as soon as he's
finished here with that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and if
you guys want to see more Deadpool
videos let me know now we'll catch you
guys later peace
you